foreign
let's go to Madeline
back to Kansas City we're going to
Kansas City but on the Missouri side
what's up Madeline yes hey how are you
you're like don't don't ever loot me in
with Kansas
absolutely not people think the Civil
War is going to be between New York and
L.A it's super not it's going to be
Missouri versus Kansas that's where it's
going to start 100
so thanks for having me listen don't
fight Kansas they're great I love kids
all right so what's up
so um I'm calling today because
um I was just curious navigating dating
in 2022
um how do you balance contentment and
singleness while longing for a life
partner
I'm an old married guy I don't know I
know you tell me
so I'm almost 30 years old and I've
never dated let me tell you how come
it's just never presented itself no no
why haven't you dated
I honestly have never been asked but
something I've struggled with is
reaching out and trying to find
connection but often being met with
um rejection or ghosting so it's like
trying to initiate that just to even
have basic connection and not even with
the intent of like I'm gonna marry you
but just trying to you know become
friends and be connected and have those
relationships but it's it has just been
um a dead end and I am just kind of in a
rut and
kind of lost so I need some guidance
yeah
I think beneath you you're smiling while
you're talking because that's what you
do
um
I can hear it in you
yeah it's it's like you've got the same
you got this thing duct tape together
is that fair
yes
so let me get behind the
people just ghost me behind the nobody's
ever asked me
beneath all of that
somebody told Madeline that Madeline's
not worth hanging out with
Madeline's not beautiful enough anyone
would ever kiss her
nobody will find Madeline this or nobody
to find that
what has here's what I'm getting at I
see young kids
that maniacally insert themselves into
groups of people that they were not
invited to because they're just Reckless
they don't have any concept that they
might not be valued or wanted
and then I look at listen to you you
already have made me laugh you're super
articulate you're able to identify what
you're going through and cover it up
like
you're clearly brilliant
how do you get there but you are missing
the
people don't want me around
right where does that come from
I don't know I guess
I I've done some reflecting recently
because I I'm a huge fan of yours I'm
reading through your book currently I'm
almost finished with it and it's just I
it's phenomenal
um
but I've just kind of been soaking up
you know your stuff like a sponge and
just trying to apply that and I think
reflecting back like I had kind of
an uneasy childhood as far as like I
have a phenomenal family great support
system
um but
school age years
I struggled with weight I still struggle
with it a little bit
um but that's always kind of been
a piece I guess in it and I I don't know
is your struggle with appearance
something that's been noted on you or is
that something that you bring to a group
or bring to another person um
it's something I just kind of keep
inward I I don't really like to reflect
it outward but I guess
um maybe it does not sure let me say it
this way I'll give you an example for my
life okay
um I dated somebody when I was in high
school somebody that was madly wildly in
love with for all a 16 year old or 18
year old I don't know how old it was
could be in love right I don't know what
that meant but I was and I'll never
forget one time we were hanging out and
we were holding hands and then she like
on she loosened up her hand and ran it
up to inside of my arm and was holding
the inside of my arm that that meant we
were like you know like we're really
close to babies right I mean like we're
in love right right and she looked up at
me and said
you would be so cute and remember back
back when I was in school acute meant
smoking hot right she was like you would
be so cute if your teeth weren't so
yellow
and so that was years ago that's a
little bitty thing
to this day I still smile
with my mouth shut
I take pictures for a living
right I'm being videoed right now and I
smile with my mouth shut and more
importantly I'm very awkward in person
and my wife pointed this out to me a few
times over our years together
uh-huh um she said I'll walk into a
situation and then I'll lean back
and I mumble because I keep my mouth
closed all the time but I talk so much
that I just in this mumbling stream of
Jo here's the thing all of that is my
insecurity from a 16 year old girlfriend
in reality I got yellow teeth they're
not sparkly white like my friend Rachel
my friend George like they like they
open their mouth and it's blinding right
I don't have that I'm not that right
um and
I have taken my insecurity in that area
and I just throw it like a cast net over
everybody in my in my vicinity
and so I bring my insecure to other
people and what my wife has told me is
it's unnerving because people see you
John they see me and they think that
guy's cool that guy does this he's got a
good job he's like this why is he so
weird around me it must be me and then
they back up because they don't want to
be the weird person
okay see what I'm saying yeah so it
might not be you the person who thinks
that they don't look right or that
they're not beautiful enough
and it might be
she acts super weird around me and I
think she's pretty Rad or she's
hilarious or I think she's beautiful
but I feel weird around her you see what
I'm saying that's the difference between
walking into a situation and saying I'm
freaking Madeline from Missouri
I deserve to be in every space I walk
into and if you don't want to be in that
space with my big smile
and my whatever I look like then you are
free to go and that's on you not on me
and that's a completely different
composite than I have a crush on you and
I want to date you but I know that I'm
not as pretty as I think I could be for
you and so I'm just gonna try to get
really small
see how different that is
right
I'm sorry yeah
no I I you you've just articulated I
think a lot of shins and like a little
hamster wheel of thoughts in my in my
mind
so the best way out of off the hamster
wheel is not more thinking it's doing
right and that's the worst it's the
worst
yes right so uh I'll tell you I'll tell
you this story and then we can we can
try to come up with a solution or a
couple of solutions we can't solve it I
I it would be it would be dishonest and
disingenuous of me to be like all right
here's how you date in the 21st century
I don't know here's what I do know a
buddy of mine got divorced a few years
ago and we're out to lunch and I was
kind of living vicariously through him I
was like all right dude you're dating
again like what's it like I'll never
forget we were like in some burger joint
in Texas
and he takes the sets his food down and
he wipes his wipes his mouth off and he
leaned in across the table and he said I
don't care how bad it gets at your house
man never never never never break up you
got to stay together man this crazy out
here and I was like what do you mean he
goes it's insane everybody's nuts and he
went on to explain like remember when
you would meet somebody like a church or
at a bar or something and you'd say hi
and get their number now they call the
police if you do that he goes exactly
it's stalking you can't do that you have
to follow them on the internets for a
while and anyway he just is like a whole
new planet opened up so my first thought
is to date in the 21st century you
should probably take uh online
programming class maybe that would help
like interact with the internet I don't
know
um here's here's a more truthful answer
I think you need to practice being
around people and catching yourself when
you start to feel awkward or not a part
of the group
and when you feel yourself begin to lean
back when you feel yourself I laugh too
loud
I don't look good in this shirt
begin to really challenge those thoughts
is this true
okay could you stand to lose weight
probably possibly
right I could right
is that the reason nobody loves you no
it's not
is that the reason why you're single no
it's not
okay okay
there's something behind that that means
you're gonna have to spend a season
being weird and uncomfortable which is
probably the two things you spent your
life avoiding
being the weird one and the
uncomfortable one is that fair
yes okay expect rejection expect failure
expect crash and burns expect to lean in
and kiss somebody and then be like what
are you doing or expect somebody to lean
and kiss you and their breath is so bad
your eyebrows fall out expect all those
things misreading signals all of that
okay you've never done it so you got to
be graceful with yourself
and there are a few people on the planet
who have made more dating mistakes than
I have I was the worst at it I was the
most clueless [ __ ] I just didn't see I
just didn't
and I just kept getting back up and
going again
mostly because I was too stupid to know
any different to know any difference
so when I'd say
ask folks out have a regularly a regular
weekly gathering at your house with a
couple of strangers or people from work
or people from your local church or
people from the Y I don't care
tell me what that does in your body
cultivate that and have people over and
host and do the things okay but
um
I guess maybe I do it in a safe manner I
do it with the people that I've known
the longest and what I'm closest to but
um are you gonna date any of them
no
so that's here's what that's like that's
like you
um going to a pond on your granddad's
farm and uh because I just assume
everybody in Missouri has a farm and you
know there's no fish in there but that
is the pond that makes you the most
comfortable and then you just cast your
line in there and sit all day and you're
like I'm terrible at fishing fish don't
like me that's not true you just know
that that's your that's your ride or die
group that's not your romance group
right is that fair
yes so you gotta be weird okay where do
we go to meet the people go first bring
them to you
bring them to you
invite five or six people from work over
and and this is gonna sound ridiculous
but what we're doing is we're practicing
being awkward
okay we're practicing not overdoing it
when it comes to I'm trying to to alter
my appearance so that I can feel like I
am fill in the blank
we're just going to be you you're going
to practice not cleaning up your house
and making it look like it's an HDTV
reveal every time somebody walks over to
your house
you're gonna practice feeling
comfortable and loved in your own skin
okay is that fair
yes that's very fair you called me out
on the HGTV
but all that all that is that's just
make up for your home
that's an extra large shirt to cover up
your body for your home
that is saying no to something that you
really want to go to because you just
feel like you're not having a pretty day
and then blaming them for not calling
you again after they've been rejected a
few times by you
is that fair
that's 100 fair and and and because I
can hear the people on the internet
screaming too
you may have to address your health
and yeah
issues but that's something that's a
priority okay for me make that priority
because you're worth a life where your
knees don't hurt and your back doesn't
hurt you don't have headaches all the
time
not to get somebody to sleep with you
you see the direction the difference
there
one is maniacal and pathological and
chasing a moving Target that you can
never catch one is looking in the mirror
and smiling
you see the difference
yes
let's be healthy let's take care of
ourselves let's be a good Steward of our
bodies because Madeline's worth a really
fun awesome life
not because she wants to hook up with
Dan Dan's the worst Madeline you know
is that fear
yes it's fair okay
become the best version of you you can
be and okay just go be weird don't be
weird okay
perfect listen will you
um
commit to going out go being weird for
the next 30 45 days inviting people over
setting up a thing I'm gonna send you
all of the questions for humans cards I
got
oh my gosh thank you so
much kids the adults pack I'll send them
all okay perfect and I want you to use
them
uh invite people over and say hey we're
gonna play these games and if those
games are lame do do another game just
come over and play games or we're gonna
play Truth or Dare we're gonna play kid
games whatever the thing is
um
let's invite people over and there's
gonna be people like this sucks you're
weird and there's gonna be three or four
people that are like dude that was the
most fun I've had a long time
and they're gonna cut there that's
you're gonna find your Rider dies and
they're gonna bring a friend next time
they come and then they're gonna bring
somebody else and then suddenly you're
gonna look across the room and be like
there it is see what I'm saying
but that's from the inside out not the
outside in
okay and if we come to Kansas will you
come to the show
um 100 I'm there
oh incredible dude it's gonna be a disco
Madeline I can't even wait it's not on
the calendar but I can't even wait hey
thank you for being brave Madeline I'm
grateful for you